hello and in this video we're gonna
cover a common conversation which is
kubernetes versus danke but Before we
jump into that I want you to hit the
subscribe button so you get notified
about new content as it gets made
available and if you hit the
notification button without notification
will then pop up on your desktop as a
video is published from simply learn in
addition if you have any questions on
the topic please post them in the
comments below we read them and we do
reply to them as often as we can so with
that said let's jump into kubernetes
versus docker
so let's go through a couple of
scenarios as to one for kubernetes and
then one for docker and we can actually
go through and understand what the
problems specific companies have
actually had and how they're able to use
the two different tools to solve them so
our first one is with bows and bows had
a large catalog of products that kept
growing and their infrastructure had to
change so the way that they looked at
that was actually establishing two
primary goals to be able to allow their
product groups to be able to easier more
easily catch up to the scale of their
business so after going through a number
of solutions they ended up coming up
with a solution of having kubernetes
running their iot platform as a service
inside of Amazon's AWS cloud service and
what you'll see with both these products
is they're very cloud friendly but here
we have bows and kubernetes working
together with AWS to be able to scale up
and meet the demands of their product
catalog and so the result is that we're
able to increase the number of non
production deployments significantly by
taking the number of services from being
large bulky services down to small micro
services being able to handle as many as
1250 and plus deployments every year an
incredible amount of time and value has
been opened through the use of
kubernetes now let's have a look at
docker and see what a similar problem
that people would have so the problem is
with paypal and paypal and processes
something in the region of over 200
payments per second
across all of their products when PayPal
doesn't just have paper they have
Braintree and venmo
so the challenge that PayPal was really
being given is that they had different
architectures which resulted in
different maintenance cycles and
different deployment times and overall
complexity from having a decades-old
architecture with PayPal through to a
modern architecture with a venmo through
the use of docker paper was able to
unified application delivery and be able
to centralize the management of all of
the containers with one existing group
the net net result is that paper was
able to migrate over 700 applications
into doggit enterprise which consists of
over 200,000 containers this ultimately
opened up a 50% increase in availability
for being able to and add in additional
time for building testing and deploying
of applications just a huge win for
PayPal let's dig into kubernetes and
darker as the kubernetes is an open
source platform and it's designed for
being able to maintain a large number of
containers and what you're gonna find is
that your argument for kubernetes versus
darker isn't a real argument its
kubernetes and darker working together
so kubernetes is able to manage the
infrastructure of a containerized
environment and docker
is the number one container management
solution and so with docker you're able
to automate the deployment of your
applications you know to keep them in a
very lightweight environment and being
able to create a nice consistent
experience so that your developers are
working in the same containers that are
then also pushed out to production so
with dr. you're able to manage multiple
containers running on same hardware much
more efficiently than you are with a VM
environment the product if T around
docker is extremely high you're able to
keep your applications very isolated the
configuration for document is really
quick and easy you can be up and running
in minutes with docker once you have it
installed and running on your
development machine or inside
DevOps environment so we look at the
deployment between the two and the
differences Cuba Nettie's is really
designed for a combination of pods and
services in its deployment whereas with
docker
it's around about deploying surfaces in
containers so the difference here is
that kubernetes is going to manage the
entire environment and then and that
environment consisting of pods and
inside of a pod you're gonna have all of
your containers that you're working on
and those containers are can control the
services that actually power the
applications that are being deployed
kubernetes is by default an auto scaling
solution it has it turned on and is
always available whereas docker does not
and and that's not surprising because
docker is a tool for building out
solutions whereas kubernetes is about
managing your infrastructure kubernetes
is going to run health checks on the
liveness and readiness of your entire
environment so not just one container
but tens of thousands of containers
whereas docker is going to limit the
health check to the services that it's
managing within its own containers now
I'm not going to kid you cubed ''tis is
quite hard to set up is of the tools
that you will be using in your DevOps
environment isn't it's not an easy setup
for you to use and for this reason you
want to really take advantage of these
surfaces within asher and other similar
cloud environments where they actually
will do the setup for you Dokka in
contrast is really easy to set up you
can as I mentioned earlier you can be up
and running in a few minutes as you
would expect the fault tolerance within
kubernetes is very high and this is by
design because the architecture of
kubernetes is built on the same
architecture that Google uses for
managing its entire cloud infrastructure
in contrast docker has lower fault
tolerance but that's because it's just
managing the the surfaces within its own
containers what you'll find is that most
public cloud providers will fight
support for both kubernetes and darker
here we've highlighted Microsoft Azure
because they were very quick to jump on
and support kubernetes but the
jeez is that today Google Amazon and
many other providers asked having first
level support for kubernetes has just
become extremely popular in a very very
short timeframe the companies using both
kubernetes and docker is fast and every
single day there are more and more
companies using it and you should be
able to look and see whether or not you
can add your own company to this list
thank you I hope you've learned
something about the difference between
kubernetes and darker it's not really
kubernetes versus docker but it's how
kubernetes and docker complement each
other if you have any questions please
post them in the comments below now we
do read them and we do respond to them
if you like taunted hit the subscribe
button and then if you happen in it
right hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch a
similar video - nerd up and get
certified click here